- You've probably heard
a lot of talk lately
about bots on Twitter or
even foreign involvement
in our political process.
For example, the president
of the United States
publicly thanked a Twitter account
which we now know was
run by malicious actors
located somewhere in Russia.
Now, depending on what
your political views are
you might be inclined to roll your eyes
and make some kind of joke
about the president being tricked,
but this is far more than that.
This reply is totally
something I would do.
If an account with over 100,000 followers
Tweeted something nice to me
I think an appropriate
response would be thank you
because that person is
clearly very influential.
When you look closer at this tweet
and really start to think about it
with an unbiased point of view you start
to realize the incredible
act of deception here.
And I'm not just talking
about deceiving the president to reply,
I'm talking about the 100,000 people
that signed up to follow this account
thinking that it was a
group if like-minded people
located in Tennessee,
when it was actually a malicious puppeteer
sitting somewhere across the globe.
Twitter is under attack.
It's a beautiful platform made for free,
open discussion about different ideas.
But the people that are
attacking Twitter every day
are trying to control the discussion
so they can ultimately
control those ideas.
The goal is to promote tribalism
and sow discord in society.
This is the second part
of a three-part series
we're doing on SmarterEveryDay
about attacks against our
social media platforms.
And we're gonna address today
what Twitter calls platform manipulation.
Today we're gonna look at
data and we're gonna talk
to experts face to face
so we can understand
what these malicious
people are trying to do,
how they're trying to do it
and the most important thing of all,
how you can get smarter
so that you don't take the bait?
We're going straight to the source
so let's go to Twitter
Headquarters in San Francisco
and speak to the team in charge
of protecting the platform
against these types of attacks.
I'm Destin.
- I'm Del.
- Del, nice to meet you.
So you're over Trust and Safety,
is that right?
- That's correct.
- At Twitter
and trust and safety in general
is keeping people safe on the Internet.
- That's the goal.
- Okay, first question,
are we under attack on the Internet?
Are there people actively trying
to do things to change the way we think?
- Absolutely, right.
That's what advertising is.
- Yeah, good point, yeah.
- And even when you get past advertising
there's this whole fascinating world
of things that people do
and the reason that I kind of pause
when people say attack is
that people who are trying
to get the word out about
something they believe in
or who are trying to raise
awareness of something,
engaged in a lot of the same behaviors
that you might think of
when you're actually talking
about somebody who's
trying to maliciously skew
the information available
on a given topic.
- There's another issue
you're probably hearing
a lot about on Twitter these days
and that's accounts getting
censored or suspended.
The first reason is
Twitter's value system.
You can go read about
that on their website
if you want but I'm just
gonna tell you straight up,
that's beyond the scope
of what I wanna get into
in this episode of SmarterEveryDay.
If Twitter is censoring people
because of their ideas,
Twitter has to own that.
However, on the flip side I also need
to understand that there
is a battle going on
behind the scenes to try
to keep the platform usable
and free from manipulation.
If you were to make your
own social media platform
you'd have to make a decision
between two extremes.
On the one side you could
run it like the Wild West,
which kind of sounds nice at first
until you realize that anything goes
and stuff starts to clutter
up like your spam folder.
On the other side you
could be a totalitarian
but that's not good for
liberty or free expression.
So the trick here is
to do a balancing act.
You wanna make the most amount of people
on the platform happy but at the same time
have just enough rules
so you keep the platform usable.
- So back in the day we
had the trending topics
and the original way that
we did trending topics
was that it would be what are the things
that are being talked
about the most on Twitter?
In a way,
they were under attack,
if you will,
because the top trend every
day was Justin Bieber.
- Yeah.
- We were under attack.
- The Beliebers were...
- Specifically the Brazilian Beliebers
(man laughing)
who wanted Justin Bieber
to come to Brazil.
- Really?
- So what they would do is every morning
they would wake up,
they would log onto Twitter
and they would start tweeting.
@justinbieber I love you,
come to Brazil one.
come to Brazil three.
And they were doing the number
because we'd already made the fix
that you couldn't do
exactly duplicate text.
So now they were adding a number onto it.
And you would look at these
accounts...
- It sounds
like a joke but it's not.
- It's totally not.
These were real people.
This was not automated.
We ended up going,
this is not actually a reflection
of what we want trending topics to be.
So we made the change,
the first change,
which was we're going to actually
rather than just saying, okay,
well this is the topic that's
being mentioned the most,
we're going to shift to
trying to really focus
on how fresh a topic is?
- Now, these fans weren't
automating their tweets
but automation is actually allowed
by Twitter's terms of service.
This leads to all kinds of really fun
and useful automation accounts,
Year and Progress,
Medieval Death Bot.
A guy named Jeff and I run an account
called WhoIsInSpace and
we occasionally operate
that in autonomous mode.
But these bots can get
out of control quickly.
If they're allowed,
how do you filter out the bad ones?
So we've all seen these nasty bots, right?
They've got suggested pictures on there
and they try to get you to click a link
so they can get all your money.
I used to see these all the time
but I don't really see them anymore.
I'm freaking impressed that you guys
are doing as well as you are
because I guess it was two years ago
I could see all this bot content
and you've fixed that,
at least in my feed.
So I imagine there was
a great amount...
- Hopefully not just yours.
- Yes, but there was a great amount
of engineering effort
that went into that, I'm assuming.
Those bots had a certain countermeasure
to get around your gates and safeguards.
You fixed that so now the bots
are doing counter, countermeasures.
And so now what you're about
to do is a counter,
counter, countermeasure.
- Eventually you just get up
to an absurd number of counters.
There are all sorts of additional things
that you can do,
speed bumps that you can
put in to do little checks
to test what behavior
happen when you try X.
So for example,
there's an account and we're just like,
something about this doesn't seem right.
Maybe it's automated.
We can throw a CAPTCHA at it.
Did it pass the CAPTCHA?
It passed the CAPTCHA,
that doesn't mean it's not automated.
It could mean that they've just purchased,
having somebody who's going to do CAPTCHAs
that are thrown at it.
Okay, let's go ahead and have them confirm
that they have access to the email address
associated with the account.
We're gonna send them
a password reset link.
Did they get there?
How fast did they get there?
How long did it take them
to verify that, right?
So you have to maintain access
to email addresses
associated with your account.
You can't just use burner emails.
You have to be able to
go back and log into it.
And look, friction can take
any number of forms, right.
- That's the term you use, friction?
- Yeah, friction.
And there are things that
are necessary friction.
There are things that are
unnecessary friction, right.
There's things where we really need
to make this experience easier for people.
- I personally experienced this friction
that Del is talking about.
I recently signed up for
a new Twitter account.
It's for something I
wanna do in the future
and I went to tweet for the
first time after two weeks
and the account was already suspended.
I hadn't done anything
so why am I suspended?
That's kind of weird and irritating.
So to try to get a better picture
of what's going on let's speak
to a technical engineer
to try to understand
what they're doing?
So this is Joel here at Twitter
and what team are you on?
- We're the Site Integrity
Team in Trust and Safety.
- The Site Integrity,
so by site integrity
you basically sniff out bots
and you knock them down,
kind of thing.
- We obviously are focused
on removing malicious
activity from the service.
We have taken really substantial steps,
especially in the last few years
to address some of the most common forms
of platform manipulation,
like bots and automation.
We're challenging eight and a half
to 10 million bots a week
of which about three quarters of them wind
up removed totally
automatically from the service.
So it's not like I'm sitting there
and I'm like
- Wait, wait, wait.
I'm sorry, how many a week?
- Eight to 10 million accounts a week
are challenged automatically
and more than three
quarters of those accounts
wind up removed automatically
from the service.
- That is a stupid big number.
I mean, think about this,
congratulations, welcome to
the team here at Twitter.
You've got the job.
Here are 10 million accounts,
go figure out which ones are humans based
on their behavior.
I just realized that you
might be doing things
far more subtly than I realized.
Okay, for example,
if I get my phone,
I'm grabbing my phone.
I'm scrolling my tweet feed
and they're loading below.
The rate at which they load is correlated
to a physical thumb movement of a human.
Do you factor that in,
that kind of stuff?
Like when you say human behavior,
are those the types of
things that you look at?
- I don't wanna reveal too much.
- Okay, got it, got it.
And to be clear,
the reason you don't wanna reveal too much
is you need to keep all
of your countermeasures secret
because the moment someone understands
your countermeasures
they could exploit those.
- I think it's very real
that there's an arms race
around platform manipulation.
And it's our job as a company
and it's my team's job to try
and stay one step ahead of attackers.
But whenever you get really
good at cracking down
on a certain pattern of behavior
an attacker is going to adapt some
of what they're doing to try
and exploit something that they perceive
as a weakness.
And so it can't just be one person
or one team of people.
Our top priority as a company
is combating these issues
and there's a lot of
people who are working
on every angle of it.
- Twitter's free, all
you need is an account
and attackers are trying
to manipulate Twitter
by using computers to
automate the sign up process.
Twitter's forced to use
artificial intelligence
to defend the platform
because these computers never sleep
and there's not enough
humans to do the job.
The problem is these bad guys
are starting to make themselves
as authentically human
as possible in order
to sneak on the platform.
Heck, in some cases they are human.
Add to this deception the sheer number
of signups and you can start to see
how it's possible to miss some of these
and let them slip past the defenses.
Speaking of defenses,
after the first episode in this series
I was contacted
by the NATO Strategic
Communications Center
and yes, I'm talking
about the North Atlantic
Treaty Organization.
I was given a report
written by Sebastian Bay
who works with the NATO
Strategic Communication
Center of Excellence to track all kinds
of stuff related to NATOs interests.
Okay, I'm on Skype with Sebastian Bay.
Happy 70th birthday of NATO,
by the way.
Sebastian has worked on this report,
Manipulating Social Media,
The Black Market for
Social Media Manipulation.
Do you mind introducing
yourself so everyone knows?
- Yes, my name is Sebastian Bay.
I'm a Senior Expert with NATO Strategic
Communications Center of
Excellence in Riga, Latvia.
- You've basically infiltrated
these black markets
and you understand how they
work at this point, right?
- So we've mapped the market.
We've looked at all the
different resellers out there.
We've looked at prices.
We've looked at methods.
We've basically seen what are they selling
and how are they trying to
manipulate social media?
How easy is it to buy a
click or a like out there
and how effective are they?
- When it comes to Twitter profiles
what are you seeing on the black market?
- So I should take one step back,
so we've been looking at Twitter
for quite some time actually
and we published a report
called Robotrolling,
which is a quarterly product where we look
at manipulation of Twitter
when it comes specifically
to NATO issues in the Baltic's.
And when we started looking specifically
at this topic two years ago,
as much as 70% of all activity relating
to NATO and the Baltic's
was actually manipulated.
It was done by inauthentic bot accounts.
That has gone down significantly though.
Today it's down to the low tens.
- What?
So 70% of all,
on that specific topic online,
because yeah, why are
people tweeting about NATO?
And the answer is.
- And the Baltic's, yeah.
So when we looked at NATO and the Baltic's
and especially in Russian,
we could see that that environment
was extremely polluted.
Most of those accounts
are very simple bots.
They don't have a history
and they're only there
to inflate the account
or to make a certain topic trend, etc..
Twitter's done a lot
actually to sure-up this
but we can still see that
these very simple accounts
and these very simple
bots can live as long
as five to six thousand tweets
before they get taken down.
- So in your estimation,
the new countermeasures
that Twitter is developing,
is it being effective?
- Yes, in terms of it has removed a lot
of the simple bot activity.
But we're seeing different
kinds of manipulation instead
where we see more of
these anonymous accounts
that are pushing content.
So these are more developed
inauthentic accounts
that are used for different
kinds of social media manipulation.
But when it comes to Twitter's response
to these simple Twitter manipulation,
that has been effective.
That has gone down over
the past few years.
- How do these fake people get around
those countermeasures
that Twitter's developing?
- Loads of different ways
but when we talked to these people,
because we've interviewed people
that sell these things,
they'd say that when
social media platforms
put new regulation into
account, into effect,
it takes them about two or three weeks
to counter those new speed bumps
that they put in,
if you wanna use that word.
And they do that by being inventive,
simply by trial and error.
If they put in a CAPTCHA service,
well, they do ways to break that.
If they put geofencing on IP addresses
they use proxies, etc., etc..
So it's become more difficult
but we're seeing,
so far we don't see any
limitation on the supply side.
So you can buy fake activity
on Twitter for an example
within 15 minutes if you
have a PayPal account.
Many of the people we have spoken to
that do these engineering,
they are people that live
in developing countries
but also in developed countries.
- So the people that buy
and sell these services
on the black market are
obviously intelligent
and they're there with intent.
There's automated bots,
there are actual humans.
What is it they want
to do on the platform?
To try to figure this out let's go back
to talk to Renée DiResta.
She's an expert
in understanding social
media manipulation.
So my understanding is the game on Twitter
is to try to amplify inauthentic behavior
using a bot or an account
that you've taken over
or something like that,
is that how the game works?
- Yes, so what you wanna do
is you wanna get your message
to reach the greatest number of people.
And so you'll have bot accounts
that just do it in an automated way,
but Twitter's gotten
better at detecting those.
So then you have people
who literally sit there
and operate the account
some percentage of the time.
Sometimes it's an agency,
sometimes it's just a regular person.
One of the main things
that Twitter's great
for though is there's
tons of journalists on it,
which means if you
wanna manipulate a story
out of the social ecosystem and get it
onto the nightly news,
Twitter's a great way to do that
if you wanna get it into a newspaper.
'Cause once something
gets a sufficient amount
of attention on Twitter,
- Critical mass.
- yep, then the press
will pick it up.
- Clearly this is news,
I should put it on my news
channel that I have.
- You got it.
And it's hard because for a long time,
especially through 2016 you would see
stuff would just trend,
just show up in the trending algorithm.
And then if the press wrote about it
it was giving it more attention.
If they were debunking it
they were still giving it attention.
And then if they didn't write about it
you'd have this next wave of accounts
speculating about why the mainstream media
was ignoring it?
So there was really no winning.
The whole game was if
you could get something
to critical mass on
Twitter you could just gain
that attention economy
and get massive lift,
reach millions and millions of people.
- Trying to get something
to trend in the news
is more than just trying to
make money on the platform.
This is a malicious, clever thing.
Sebastian said he is seeing those types
of services reflected
in the black markets,
something he calls meta manipulation.
I understand everybody now thinks
about the Russian bots
and the 2016 election
but I have to understand
that the countermeasures
have been developed and
people know about that now,
so they're already moving on
to a different type of manipulation.
What's going on now?
- And what we're seeing now is a lot
of focus on meta manipulation.
So that means that you
inflate the view counts
to trick the algorithms
of different social media platforms
to make your own content
trend on those platforms.
So we've run experiments
where we've bought bot activity.
When we do that,
that attracts real viewers
because the platforms think
that they are trending.
So this sort of meta manipulation,
that's what we're seeing now.
That's what many of these
resellers are promoting.
- So this is alarming obviously
but there's something
that's even more disturbing about this.
These accounts are the low tier accounts.
There's a higher tier account that exists.
That one is more expensive to create,
more expensive to operate
and is more devious.
It's specifically tailored
to misrepresent to misrepresent
a specific group of people.
Accounts like this may actually
have several thousand
actual human followers.
- And you can actually buy almost any kind
of custom made account.
If you want a Swedish
female who's been online
for 10 years that has several friends
with specific interests you can request
that from these vendors
that sell accounts.
- Really, so you can tailor
the specific demographic
of the inauthentic account that you want
to use for manipulation?
- Sure.
- If you're trying
to attack the African American community
and create divisiveness
in the African American community
you can buy that kind of account online,
or if you're trying
to attack a specific political group,
you can do the same?
- Yeah, it's exactly like that.
- These specialized accounts
are hyper interesting
social media weapons.
Think about it,
they're like a Trojan Horse
because they can get you access to places
that you're not expecting.
They're like a false flag operation
because they're
misrepresenting what they are
in order to blame
something on somebody else.
And with these weapons you can perform
precision strikes because you can target
a very specific individual
on a very specific issue.
- Twitter is also an incredible way
to reach influencers because celebrities
are all on there with
millions of followers,
and if they retweet you your message
just hits millions of people
or to reach the press,
which is also on there.
And so that's how you have,
if you get something trending on Twitter
reporters will pick it
up and then it winds
up on the front page of
The Times the next day.
- So the idea is to
trick influential people
and then use those as a vehicle
to get this inauthentic
information out there?
- Yep, Twitter is a...
- So if you have more followers you
have a higher standard,
you have to be even more
serious about what you tweet.
- Absolutely, yeah.
You've gotta be really careful.
When you think about if
you retweet something
that's wrong you have just pushed it out
to potentially hundreds
of thousands of people
and they're not gonna
see you necessarily push
out the correction.
- So when Twitter finds
some of the bad guys
they collect all the
data and then they'll do
one big data release so
you can pour through it
and see what's going on?
People in academia are studying this stuff
to try to develop AI methods
to detect these people
and counteract them.
It's a cat and mouse game.
One of the most interesting
thing that's happened
is congress released a
report with thousands
of the actual Twitter
account names on them.
If you pour through this
data you'll figure out
that there's three basic categories.
There's accounts on the left,
accounts on the right and
then there's this weird
local news category.
I think it would be helpful to explain
what an attack against
you would look like?
It's gonna come in the form of a retweet
from a friend.
It's gonna be something funny
that you resonate with.
There's a single moment
you need to be looking for
and this is the tell,
because you're not going
to detect these accounts.
Even the CEO of Twitter retweeted one
of these accounts when they're
tweeting all this stuff,
the feel good stuff.
But the moment you're
looking for is a nudge,
the nudge to think a negative thought
against another group of people.
If you belong to a certain demographic set
or like a value system or belief system
and you see someone saying something like,
oh well, they always think that,
we don't do that,
or something like that, that's it.
That nudge to think
something against them,
that's what you're looking for.
- With terrorism there's
a more clearly defined
set of things that are bad
or there's a clearly defined organization.
- 'Cause there's a literal
battlefield.
- There is, yeah.
(lady laughs)
- And this is the battlefield
of the mind.
- Right.
- This is
a battlefield of the mind
where the enemy hides behind civilians.
And the enemy has the added advantage
that when they are
revealed as being an enemy
you basically start to
distrust those around you,
which was one of their
goals to begin with.
They're trying to get
you to not trust people
in your own community.
It's very subtle but it's very complex.
- Right now there's a really strong fear
of false positives leading
to unfair take downs.
I mean, you're a content creator, right.
This is never a thing
that you wanna see happen
and so the question becomes
how do you send up a flair saying we think
that this account might be
something that we should have a look at?
We think this account
might be inauthentic.
We think this account might be foreign,
pretending to be
- because the minute
- something else.
- you have a
false positive,
- The Internet explodes.
- The Internet explodes
because Chubbywabs385
or whatever, surfing
engine 385 gets upset.
If you rewind to what
I said at the beginning
of the video and think
about the suspension,
this yes, some of these are as a result
of management-making policy decisions
about how people are
interacting on the platform
and things like that.
But there's this other category,
engineers are literally
taking out malicious accounts
at a rate of over 12 per second.
Against an enemy that's
constantly adapting,
I can tell you,
these tools they're
developing are not perfect
so it is not unreasonable to expect
that every once and a
while, unfortunately,
there's gonna be an
innocent bystander caught
in the crossfire.
- The diversity of behaviors that we see
are more wild than you
can possibly imagine
and it's international,
it's different communities
of people on Twitter.
I'll give you an example from last night.
We have been working on developing
some new machine learning models
to help us identify potential groups
of accounts engaged in
political manipulation.
- Okay, it's an election year.
Got it.
- Yeah.
- Or it's election season starting.
- It's always, it's an election somewhere,
all the time, forever.
So this is obviously a big priority for us
and we were looking at some of the output
of this model and we identified
this group of accounts
that looked like they were impersonating
local police departments
and mayors of towns.
- Holy crap.
- And I was looking
at them and I'm like,
what is happening here?
There's like 50 of these accounts.
This is like clear manipulation.
This was a problem.
And then I saw that one of the mayors
was tweeting about being in a K hole
and I'm like hang on a second,
why is this mayor on ketamine and talking
about that on Twitter?
And then I realized that
all of these accounts
were operated by somebody
who was role playing
as characters from the Grand
Theft Auto video games.
All of the cities that they were operating
these accounts from were
places where a GTA game
has been set and they
built up this elaborate
fantasy role playing
community with accounts
on Twitter that were talking to each other
as if they were in the GTA Universe.
- Something negative happens,
you make a decision and you take
down Aunt Suzie's gymnastics
class or whatever.
- Sorry, Aunt Suzie.
- You take that down
because it gets rolled up
in some of these attempts
to take down legitimate manipulators,
so they hate you because
you're big, corporate Twitter.
And at that point in time you,
an engineer, sitting there saying,
I just wanna help people.
That's hard, how do you deal with that?
Because people love to hate you
and you are trying to help them,
how do you deal with that?
How do you sleep with that?
- We treat all those moments of outrage
as learning opportunities.
I think when people are mad
at a company like Twitter,
and this is hard,
I spent my first couple
of years at Twitter
struggling with how angry people are
if you get it wrong
and how to manage that?
But ultimately, I think the majority
of them are mad because
they want us to be better
and they want Twitter to be a community
where they can really
participate and engage
and get informed and they want it
to be the best platform it can be.
And so as a company I
think we take a mindset
of wanting to learn from that,
to be humble about it,
to understand where we can do better
and if we take down Aunt
Suzie's gymnastics class
because something about
it seemed like spam,
we're gonna really dissect that moment
and try and figure out what
tripped this algorithm?
What caused us to do that?
Do we think that's right?
And this is a 1% error
rate that we think is just
in the interest of everyone on Twitter.
- It's millions of people.
- Right, the challenge of
scale is 1% of 300 million
is a lot.
So we're always trying
to balance those things.
- Speaking of balance,
if you watch this video
and your whole takeaway is,
we'll, I'm just not gonna trust anybody
on the Internet,
then there's an argument to be made
that I just played into the enemy's hand
by making this video.
If they hide behind civilians
and then when we figure it out the result
is to not trust anybody around you,
that is not good.
These are our neighbors.
That is next level psychological warfare
that they're hitting us with.
I'm gonna podcast and my cohost Matt and I
have this phrase that we
use a lot, political grace.
If the point of these
attacks is to divide us
then proactive, intentional
unity has the potential
to be an effective countermeasure
on the personal level.
Maybe we should just not assume the worst
of each other.
And that extends to the people
that are developing these
countermeasures at Twitter.
Their job is to perfectly
protect a platform
and never make a single mistake.
And frankly, it's an
impossible job that never ends.
Do you feel like in some
cases you're over matched?
- I think that we always try to assume
that we are not as advanced as the people
who are trying to attack us,
because assuming otherwise
basically puts you
in a position where it's
easy to develop blind spots.
If we are always assuming that this
is an arms race and that we should never
be patting ourselves on the back going,
we got all the countermeasures in place,
we're always going to
assume that it's evolving,
that it's evolving
quickly and that we have
to stay on top of it.
And that's really the only way
you can think about it.
(test tone)
- So in this
episode we talked about Twitter
and the specific technical
engineering countermeasures
they use to protect the platform.
Sometimes when people talk about a sponsor
at the end of the video
they just give you a URL
and tell you to go support,
in this case SmarterEveryDay,
but thought it would be more fun
to tell you the specific
technical engineering details
about how ExpressVPN protects your data?
When you go to a site on the Internet
you leave a trail of
metadata about yourself
for your ISP to collect.
I explained in the last
video that when I connect
to the ExpressVPN server with one click,
just like this,
now my data is protected.
Now, I read your comments
in the last video
and a lot of you said, well,
if all of my data is going to the server
doesn't that mean they have my data there?
Here's the thing, they don't.
They don't log any of your traffic
and they don't keep any of your data
and they way they do it is genius.
This is a Solid State Hard Drive.
Most laptops and
computers today have these
and you can read and
write to these things.
It's a form of non-volatile memory.
This is called RAM.
It's different, RAM memory is volatile.
If you ever lose power while using RAM
all the data is lost.
ExpressVPN has specifically engineered
their VPN software to run entirely in RAM
on their servers.
That is genius.
It's such a simple, elegant design.
They cannot keep logs of your data
because it all goes away
after you disconnect.
They can't mishandle your information
because it doesn't exist.
No one can hack into the
system and get your data,
it's not there.
And at this point you're
probably thinking,
well, how do you know this Destin?
They're not saying this.
A foreign government is.
A foreign government tried to seize
an ExpressVPN server in 2017
and extract data from it
and their investigation failed.
It yielded no data.
I personally get excited every time
there's a technological solution
to giving me more personal liberty.
If you want to take your
online data seriously today
you can do that by going
to ExpressVPN.com/smarter.
If you get 12 months,
you get an additional 3 months for free
and there's a 30 day money back guarantee.
It is an intelligent
way to encrypt your data
and protect yourself online.
So big thanks to ExpressVPN
for helping us make
this social media manipulation series.
This is the second video.
We've done YouTube,
this is Twitter and of
course we're gonna do
Facebook after this.
I'm thinking about expanding it to Reddit,
what do you think about that?
Anyway, big thanks to everybody.
I noticed on the last
video you were commenting
on the video,
specifically to boost it on the algorithm,
that means you get it.
Thank you so much.
Also, I'm gonna do something weird.
I've never done this on SmarterEveryDay
but I'm gonna tell you
about my Twitter account.
I normally don't talk
about my Twitter account
but come on,
I mean, if there's ever
a video to tell you
about my Twitter account this is it.
So I think if I align this
neon head up right there
you should be able to click on it
and go to a page where I've set up
all my Twitter accounts.
I've got @smartereveryday,
which is the channel, of course.
We got @destinsandlin and a couple
of other surprise ones I
don't normally talk about.
So there you go,
you can go click on the Twitter stuff.
I hope this video earned
your subscription.
This is a lot of work,
that's an understatement
so I hope you enjoyed this content.
Please feel free to share it.
I'm Destin, you're
getting smarter every day.
- Have a good one, bye.